[Aplausos]
[Música]
libería es un país africano en el que
sólo rige una ley la ley de murphy
efectivamente si algo puede salir mal en
liberia no tengáis ninguna duda de que
saldrá mal aunque claro es posible que
el iberia sea el típico país del que no
habías oído hablar y si has oído hablar
de él es porque probablemente seas un
profesional de la evasión fiscal porque
si amigos de visual político liberia es
uno de los mayores paraísos fiscales del
mundo lo que pasa es que para qué vamos
a engañarnos la vida por esta zona no es
tan glamourosa como en mónaco o las
islas cayman así que dejémoslo en que
iberia es un auténtico paraíso fiscal
para las empresas
[Música]
básicamente lo que una sociedad
liberiana ingresa por sus actividades
fuera del territorio de liberia está
absolutamente libre de impuestos
pero claro estaréis pensando porque
liada ahora
meterme en un vuelo de siete horas a
áfrica para temas de papeleo
guiada tranquilos no pasa nada pero
quien ha dicho áfrica el registro
liberiano te ofrece un montón de
oportunidades
zúrich londres tokio parecen los
protagonistas de la casa de papel pero
no son algunos de los lugares donde los
que puedes administrar una empresa
liberiana y que tiene muy poquito que
ver con la realidad de este país pero es
que no solo es un paraíso fiscal para
las empresas
si hablamos de liberia tenemos que
hablar de barcos y si de barcos es más
si vivís en un puerto de mar
estoy seguro de que habéis visto muchos
barcos con esta bandera
o tal vez habréis visto muchos barcos
con la inscripción
monrovia en el casco es el puerto de
matrícula
diréis cómo es posible que haya tantos
barcos con pabellón liberiano pues bien
agarrados esto es porque iberia es el
segundo mayor armador de buques del
mundo sólo superado por panamá y claro
os preguntaréis venga ya fonseca y esto
porque a ver si ahora va a resultar que
liberia es el singapur de áfrica un
paraíso fiscal lleno de empresas de
barcos vamos la suiza del áfrica sub
sahariana los liberianos tienen que
estar forrado
pues nada de eso liberia es uno de los
cinco países más pobres del mundo pero
no pobres en el sentido de no ser de la
india no son pobres de no tener nada es
que ahí no tienen ni taj mahal me
hollywood ni vacas nada en liberia el
pib percápita atentos no superan mil
dólares al año o sea que a su lado los
ugandeses son el doble de ricos o más
bien la mitad de pobres así que la
pregunta que os estaréis haciendo es
cómo es posible que siendo una de las
principales potencias navales del mundo
y un paraíso fiscal
liberia siga siendo un país tan pobre
hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
el paraíso afroamericano misisipí año
1820 decenas de esclavos están
recogiendo el algodón para el amo de la
plantación como todos sabéis uno de los
peores capítulos de la historia de eeuu
es la esclavitud una aberración que
terminó con la guerra civil entre los
estados del norte dirigidos por abraham
lincoln y los estados del sur que
querían seguir igual con sus
plantaciones y sus esclavos por eso
hasta que el norte ganó la guerra en el
año 1865 la esclavitud era legal en
muchos estados de los eeuu
y ahora mismo sé lo que estaréis
pensando a ver espera fonseca pero esto
no se supone que era un vídeo sobre
liberia y los paraísos fiscales que
haces hablándonos de eeuu y la
esclavitud a ver tranquilos no me vuelto
loco es que el origen de la república de
liberia se encuentra en la esclavitud de
eeuu y aquí tenemos que distinguir dos
partes la parte bonita y la parte real
veréis liberia fue fundada por esclavos
que habían recibido su libertad en eeuu
la sociedad americana de colonización se
encargó de trasladarles al territorio de
áfrica que hoy en día es la actual
liberia así que por un lado el nombre de
liberia viene del latín líder liberal
liberum que significa libre era la
tierra de las personas libres
el otro lado el nacimiento de la
república de liberia tiene poco que ver
con ese noble propósito de liberar a los
esclavos que había en eeuu y procurar su
bienestar más bien todo lo contrario lo
que querían era librarse de la población
americana libre como podéis imaginar en
aquellos años previos a la guerra civil
en eeuu había una tensión enorme entre
el norte y el sur es cierto que en el
norte había un movimiento cada vez más
grande para abolir la esclavitud y había
esclavos que conseguían su libertad
escapando a los estados del norte de
alabama a chicago por ejemplo pero claro
los del sur pensaban oye a ver estados
del norte si no dejáis de liberar a
esclavos afroamericanos en cuanto pueda
van a regresar de nuevo al sur y nos van
a provocar nos van a liar aquí una
revolución que esto va a ser porque el
rosario de la aurora es más por aquella
época hubo unas cuantas rebeliones de
esclavos así que esta fue la idea que
tuvieron en el sur para no tener
problemas con los afroamericanos libres
los mandamos lo más lejos posible van a
ir al paraíso afroamericano un lugar
donde podrán vivir y desarrollar sus
propias leyes
y por eso la sociedad americana de
colonización empezó en 1822 a fletar
barcos y 'la en europa áfrica y deja de
molestar el lugar elegido de áfrica
tampoco fue aleatorio porque justo al
lado de la actual liberia esta sierra
leona que era el lugar donde los
británicos habían hecho lo mismo con sus
esclavos básicamente la sociedad
americana de colonización llegó a esta
zona de áfrica se juntó con los líderes
locales y les compró las tierras
entregándoles bienes baratijas armas y
ron por valor atentos de 300 dólares
vamos que yo os podéis imaginar qué tipo
de negocio era aquello
[Música]
como capital del territorio fundaron una
ciudad que llamaron monrovia en honor a
james monroe que era el presidente de
eeuu por aquel entonces por cierto que
monroe también era de lita era un sueño
que tenía esclavos negros o sea que no
penséis que estaba en contra de la
esclavitud ni muchísimo menos así que en
estas circunstancias es como nació
liberia como una especie de colonia de
una sociedad estadounidense de carácter
privado en 1847 liberia se independizó y
aún así la nueva república siguió
viviendo un poco de la mano de eeuu
precisamente esa buena relación es la
que convirtió a liberia en una potencia
naval ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
una bandera de conveniencia todos estos
libertos es decir esclavos liberados
llegaron a áfrica y se quedaron con una
de las peores costumbres de eeuu la de
tener esclavos habéis oído bien ya sé
que parece mentira pero es que los
antiguos esclavos formaron una élite que
esclavizó a la población de las tribus
locales de hecho la república de liberia
fue dirigida por esta élite hasta 1980
más de un siglo a esta élite se le
conoce ahora como los américo liberianos
y como os contaba a pesar de ser una
república independiente de los lazos con
eeuu eran más que evidentes esto explica
lo que sucedió tras la segunda guerra
mundial
[Música]
como ya sabéis a partir del año 1945 el
mundo quedó dividido en dos mitades tal
y como decía winston churchill un telón
de acero había separado a occidente del
espacio soviético era el comienzo de la
guerra fría y cada país del mundo por
muy neutral que quisiera ser quedó
situado como más próximo a uno oa otro
bloque
[Música]
y todo esto significa que eeuu prohibía
a muchos de los barcos comerciales y
recalar en puertos que no fueran aliados
es decir en puertos soviéticos así que
los armadores de barcos de eeuu llegaron
a la casa blanca y dijeron pero que me
estás contando o sea que tengo ya mis
buques en altamar y ahora va a resultar
que no puedo recalar en los puertos de
la unión soviética mira a ver casablanca
no te estás enterando de la misa la
mitad tú no te preocupes tu sigue sigue
haciendo tus leyes de guerra fría y tal
que nosotros ya nos buscamos la vida y
como decimos en visual político dicho y
hecho los armadores necesitaban una
bandera neutral que no fuera el
estadounidense y pensaron en el año 1948
a ver nuestros amigos a américo liberia
nos van a hacer lo que les pidamos con
tal de que matricule mos los barcos en
liberia y ya puestos les podemos pedir
que nos lo pongan baratito así que
alcanzaron un trato que era bueno para
todos los armadores estadounidenses
dijeron a los liberianos no os
preocupéis mira nosotros ponemos la
bandera de liberia nuestros barcos os
pagamos un dinerillo y ya está no tenéis
que preocuparos por nada es más la
oficina donde vamos a hacer todos los
papeleos la vamos a poner
en virginia es decir en eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no sé si os habéis fijado antes pero en
virginia es donde están los headquarters
del registro liberiano y ahora os
preguntaréis bueno la guerra fría ya ha
pasado porque siguen registrándose los
barcos en liberia pues en primer lugar
porque como buen paraíso fiscal ofrece
discreción sobre la propiedad de los
barcos y en segundo lugar también sigue
ofreciendo muchas ventajas económicas os
acordáis de ese barco con la inscripción
monrovia que os enseñé antes pues a
fletar un portacontenedores de esta
envergadura simplemente por el registro
inicial hecho en liberia nos estamos
ahorrando unos 14.000 dólares pero como
dirían en el titanic esto sólo es la
punta del iceberg por ejemplo liberia
tiene un acuerdo para comerciar con
puertos de china que supone ahorrar un
buen puñado de miles de dólares
y mucho
liberia confirmada como el segundo
registro de buques más grandes del mundo
y que recibe a cambio liberia pues
básicamente unos dólares por el papeleo
que de otra forma ni olería y ya sé que
estamos hablando de unos impuestos
mínimos pero son lo suficiente para que
liberia se lleve un buen pellizco para
que os hagáis una idea a día de hoy el
registro de barcos le deja a la
república de liberia 25 millones de
dólares cada año posiblemente esta
cantidad os parezca poco dinero pero hay
que ponerlo en contexto liberia es un
país pequeño con 4 millones de
habitantes así que por no hacer nada ya
que el registro liberia no está dirigido
por una sociedad privada liberia recibe
el 6 por ciento de los ingresos del país
sólo por su condición de bandera de
conveniencia y vale quizás ahora
estaréis pensando aquí en el business
gordo lo están haciendo esta sociedad
privada pero como os decía si no fuera
por este negocio liberia no vería ni un
duro así que viendo este panorama
podréis pensar bueno entonces libería
estará a puntito de convertirse en el
nuevo panamá a fin de cuentas parece que
su estructura económica y su estrategia
es muy parecida pues nada de eso
tiene un montón de problemas porque pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
de la guerra civil al balón de oro en el
año 1980 un golpe de estado puso fin a
la dominación de los américo liberianos
por primera vez
iberia tenía un presidente procedente de
la población nativa lo que podía ser una
buena noticia para liberia fue en
realidad el germen de dos guerras
civiles
señores de la guerra disputas tribales y
una auténtica lucha sangrienta por el
poder podéis acudir a los tópicos que
queráis porque se cumplen todos áfrica
años 90 tráfico de armas y niños
soldados o podéis ver el señor de la
guerra que creo que es la única película
buena de nicolas cage y que además lo
explica muy bien en esta película se ve
como el personaje de nicolas cage se
aprovecha de la caída de la unión
soviética para hacerse con armas viejas
del arsenal a precio de saldo luego se
va a áfrica y se forra mientras apoya a
los dictadores más despiadados en fin
ahí se ve lo que pasaba en los años 90
en países como libería y a partir de
aquí no os voy a hacer más spoilers sólo
os diré que nicolas cage pasó de
traficante de armas a motorista
fantasma' y de ahí su carrera ya en
picado pero es el señor de la guerra de
verdad que está muy bien está muy bien
como película porque como os podéis
imaginar las guerras civiles fueron
devastadoras para liberia 2 en 14 años
con una masacre que acabó con la vida de
250.000 personas el 8 por ciento de la
población de liberia a eso podéis
sumarle otros tantos desplazados y una
economía en ruinas
[Música]
y lo que ocurrió después fue un milagro
porque la segunda guerra civil que se
saldó con el exilio del dictador charles
taylor dio lugar a una transición
democrática y desde el año 2005 hay
elecciones y elecciones realmente libres
y es verdad que el país ha mejorado no
para tirar cohetes pero después de dos
guerras civiles estáis conmigo en que
solo se puede mejorar
ellen johnson sirleaf se convirtió en
2006 en la primera mujer elegida
presidenta en áfrica gobernó liberia
durante 12 años y su periodo tuvo muchas
luces pero también muchas sombras
después de tanta turbulencia es cierto
que consiguió cierta estabilidad para el
país y con la ayuda internacional
comenzó la reconstrucción de liberia
estos méritos llevaron a sirleaf a ganar
el nobel de la paz en el lado oscuro
tenemos la corrupción no consiguió
atajar la y además su nombre se había
implicado en lost paradise papers con
una sociedad en bermudas que digo yo
para que necesitaba una sociedad en
bermudas si ya vivía en un paraíso
fiscal pero bueno también se la acusó de
nepotismo al tener a varios hijos
enchufados en las empresas estatales y
antes de que os llevéis las manos a la
cabeza pensadlo por un momento hemos
pasado de hablar de niños-soldado a
simplemente gobiernos corruptos aunque
no sea lo ideal hay que reconocer que es
un progreso
para bien todavía le queda mucho por
mejorar a este país uno de los mayores
problemas que tienen es la dependencia
de las ayudas internacionales que al
final han ido al bolsillo de los
mandamases en lugar de a desarrollar la
economía porque mis queridos amigos de
visual política liberia lleva décadas
exportando caucho cacao y tristeza es
algo así como el disneylandia de la
pobreza lideran tantos rankings
internacionales de subdesarrollo que la
ayuda internacional se vuelca con ellos
pero todo esto en lugar de favorecer los
liberianos acaba en las mismas manos de
siempre ahora bien que si pensabais
pobre iberia con sus gobernantes
corruptos esperando un momento porque
como bien dice la ley de murphy si las
cosas van mal siempre pueden ir a peor
george weah de futbolista a presidente
de liberia los que tengáis más de 30
años seguro que recordáis a george weah
el delantero del psg milán y chelsea
balón de oro en 1995 en otras palabras
uno de los mejores futbolistas del mundo
y ahora quiere llevar su éxito en el
mundo del deporte a la política y que
está lo está haciendo pues mira cuál ha
sido su principal prioridad a diario
fifty one in action fund lit y fit by
night lluvia temas en monrovia hueso
gana street ayer en ambos foros in one
by one water world fútbol
a esto lo llamamos una crisis de mediana
edad más superada básicamente organizó
un partido amistoso de la selección de
liberia sólo para volver a jugar sólo
para retirar su camiseta con el número
14 george weah que tiene 53 años y
preside uno de los países más pobres del
mundo se dedica a gastar su tiempo y su
dinero en un partido sin sentido pero
diréis bueno algo más habrá hecho pues
si apostar por las infraestructuras en
un país como liberia parece una buena
idea lo que ocurre es que las malas
lenguas dicen que se ha dedicado a
a las carreteras alrededor de la
residencia privada de los web o que ha
dado prioridad a mejorar la vida en
gibraltar el suburbio en el que pasó su
infancia y esto es lo que dicen las
malas lenguas porque como hemos dicho en
liberia si hay cosas malas siempre puede
haber cosas peores
[Música]
[Aplausos]
liberia el proyecto de re techado de wea
en gibraltar bajo escrutinio las
partidas aprobadas muestran más de un
millón de dólares gastados esta última
información asegura que hay ingenieros
profesionales que cifran el coste de
este proyecto en menos de la mitad pero
esto solo es un escándalo lo más grave
es que los que votaron por web están
despertando
[Música]
pensando por un segundo george weah era
su ídolo de la infancia un éxito único
para los liberianos un modelo a seguir
un sueño y su presidencia se está
convirtiendo en una caricatura la
economía van mal el precio de la vida
sube y no hay trabajo por supuesto que
la corrupción sigue ahí y todo eso
genera una frustración que puede poner
en peligro la estabilidad de liberia ya
han estallado varias protestas y el
riesgo de una nueva guerra civil no deja
de aumentar
[Música]
por supuesto en visor política esperamos
que no suceda pero mientras tanto la
pregunta es para vosotros tenéis que
liberia saldrá en algún momento de la
pobreza que lleva décadas arrastrando
podrán sacar provecho de su condición de
paraíso fiscal y su potencial naval
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y por supuesto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a visual
político y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]